(pensive pop music)
- [Narrator] About a
third of the United States
is covered in forests.
In places like Colorado,
those forests are in danger.
(flames crackling)
There's fire.
- [Woman] Our wildfires are getting
more frequent and larger.
- [Narrator] A devastating
beetle infestation.
- Those trees are all dead.
They don't have any branches anymore.
They're just standing sticks.
- [Narrator] And global warming.
There is hope, and it's
found in an unlikely place.
- When I tell people that I
work at a forest in Nebraska,
they usually laugh and they're like,
"Nebraska has a forest?"
(upbeat orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Richard
Gilbert is a man on a quest.
He's a biological
scientist who works here,
at the Charles Bessey
Nursery in Halsey, Nebraska.
It's the oldest federal
tree nursery in the U.S.
The nursery's main mission
is to help preserve
and repopulate national forests
in the Rocky Mountain region.
- Without Bessey,
they're not gonna be able
to have the supply of trees
that they need for reforestation.
If they have a catastrophe,
we can be there to help them.
What I love most about my job
is really the change in season
and the change in work that I do.
I get to work in the seed bank,
I get to work in the
container part of this,
and I get to work in the field,
and I get to actually get my hands dirty.
I don't just sit in an
office and push paper.
- Richard's amazing.
He really cares and he's always
trying to make it better.
- We turn the greenhouses on,
you got little seedlings germinating.
To me, it's spring.
So, my spring starts really early
and it's extremely rewarding.
- He's very proud of his work.
He's very proud of his trees.
- I love growing plants
and helping them grow.
I don't ever wanna lose that
contact with the plants.
When they need 'em, we grow 'em,
and we get 'em produced
in less than a year.
All of the trees are
produced in the greenhouses
and then they are brought
in here on tables.
This Y is okay 'cause it's above halfway
and we have a central leader.
We can pack 110,000 to 120,000
trees per belt per day.
We're packing container trees
for the San Juan National Forest.
They don't get their moisture
in the spring a lotta times.
They get their summer monsoon seasons.
That's when they want
their seedlings delivered.
- Richard remembers
all of this information
and wants the feedback and
wants to know how they did.
At our best, we might
get 70%, 80% survival.
- Without Bessey, they're
not gonna be able to have
the supply of trees that
they need for reforestation.
Plants are just amazing
and there are so many of 'em out there,
and I will never know how
to grow every single one.
If it's a very, very interesting plant,
I'll try to produce it
and grow it at the house.
And if you guys drive
by my house over there,
you'll understand;
you'll see all of the different plants
that I have over there.